Bruce here's a little bit from your new
album really yeah listen come on
from uh I'll talk it up wnbc I like this
yeah Bruce Springsteen's new album Only
the Strong survived
now we're talking yeah right 55 degrees
outside
does it bother you when radio guys
you love me talk up yes
here it comes
he was a friend of mine the boy sounds
very good and he could sing I worked
really hard on My Singing on this record
because I could choose choose music that
I could sing well rather than go the
other way you know right so and this is
just such a beautiful song Beautiful
song the guys that wrote this were
incredible you know but when you choose
songs from this kind of album where
you're going to sing other people's
songs yeah hard or like I know
immediately these are the ones I made a
entire record doing it and threw it out
so really yeah I made uh there's 15
songs on this record 40 songs left on
the floor wow you know so I still will
do that sometimes and on this record I
basically chose songs a that I love and
that based around my singing so what I'm
really proud of on this record is and
the one I'm I'm still working on at the
house also is that it's all music that I
chose based upon my voice and getting my
voice out front so it's it's a lot of
fun and just being able to sing some
others other great songs right now is is
a lot of fun for me the album I should
tell people Bruce Springsteen's new
album Only the Strong Survive there it
is we'll be available November 11th it's
weird promoting a new album isn't it now
with this business I know it doesn't
matter you know I I sort of I think it's
the thing where uh
you know I've got a sizable audience
that's interested in thankfully still
interested in what it is what's
interesting me and I but your job is as
Marty Score says he I think it was once
said the job of the artist is to make
the audience care about your obsessions
Jon Stewart was inducting you into the
um doing the Kennedy Center Honors and
um the piece they did you said something
about my career has been a lifelong
conversation with my audience sure I
never looked at it that way yeah but
that's what I'm doing and that's
definitely what you're doing and that's
what Bruce is doing you know and it's
such a beautiful way to look at it it is
and and the progression of that
conversation is essential you know I I
I'll tell you what really moved me was
your interview and Rolling Stone from
2019. that was really a it was a very
telling uh vulnerable interview and uh
and that's kind of what you were saying
was hey man you you know you've got to
change you gotta you gotta move onward
which is tough because in my business
when you come up you know you're coming
up off the street and you're a lot of
your pals are with you the biggest
insult is you changed man I know you
[ __ ] changed why did you change you
know you and you go like yeah but yeah
you didn't change yeah and I guess I
always look at it like why would you
want to listen to a guy whether he's a
musician or a guy on the radio why would
you want to listen to the same thing
over and over again don't you want to
know that I changed I have friends Sky
people come up to me when I did Tunnel
of Love was 1987 forget about now I go
oh yeah yeah no I liked it when you were
singing about the cars and the girls
right you know as soon as I started
singing about relationships no I I I you
lost me there you know so you go through
your career and you know you you pick
people up and people go by the wayside
and and that's that's the nature of but
aren't you proud of yourself
isn't it great when you can change and
you can say to your audience hey man I
managed to change yeah maybe you should
look at yourself
no life ever had no life I would had no
kids I would have had no home life and
for a while when I was young I thought
that was romantic and
quickly as I got older I realized maybe
not